kendall Jenner gets a real about her  struggle with acne the 22 year old  supermodel attended the Golden Globes on  Sunday looking a fab in a black gown but  it was her face that had people talking  one commenter tweeted at Jenner writing  quote kendall Jenner showing up and  strutting her acne while looking like a  gorgeous star is what every girl needs  to understand the reality star retweeted  the comment and replied quote to never  let that stop you showing your just true  beauty is my favorite generat ended the  awards show and the InStyle after-party  posing it up at both events and she  noted on social media that her look made  her feel like a princess but she also  acknowledged the globe's more important  message posting this pic and writing my  eyes were opened and my heart is full  seeing all the men and women who were  part of this vital change I too stand  with all women hashtag time's up  [Music]  you